it made America feel very old and tired
and not like the most happening of
places basically I was sorry and it
taken me so long to get to China it's I
was hanging out with a lot of people who
are environmentally concerned and
there's no there is no real
western-style activism there cannot be
any western-style activism
environmentally in China so it gets
channeled into these relatively safe and
acceptable forms and because of my
pre-existing interest in birds I was
hanging out with a lot of people who
cared about bird conservation and China
as as we all know somewhere between 1.3
and 1.4 billion people and very little
good land and what land there is is
pretty much as dense as you know Hoboken
New Jersey
and you just drive for hours and hours
and it never gets any less densely
populated than Hoboken which is pretty
densely populated and you keep waiting
for you know like let's get to the
actual city center and you realize well
this is you know we're not on the
outskirts this is what the countryside
looks like it's very very densely
populated and it takes some getting used
to the fact that it is almost entirely
wildlife free people won't grab you by
the arm and say look a gull you know a
seagull it's a seagull like it's the way
we react to a bald eagle or something
you know there's an actual gull there so
you drive by these harbors you you take
ferries and it's just you know brown
water as far as the eye can see because
every bit of protein is being extracted
and eaten so in in certain ways from a
biodiversity or wildlife perspective I
was in eastern China
it's very bleak conversely when you find
an animal or when you find somebody who
cares about a wild animal it just seems
like the most miraculous gift and bird
life does continue to hang on there and
there is suddenly increasingly a
homegrown community of bird watchers for
one thing people who just like once
people were no longer hungry and there
was such a thing as a middle class
almost instantly very much contrary to
our notions of Chinese eating you know
Tiger gallbladder and trafficking and
rhinoceros horn and basically you know
skinning cats and eating songbirds and
all of that in fact instantly with a
certain level of affluence comes an
ability and the leisure to appreciate
nature all of which is very heartening
until you try to do the math on what it
would take to make the entire country
affluent enough to care you would
basically need to clear-cut all of
Southeast Asia to Central Africa and the
Amazon in order to bring the Chinese
population up to European or American
standard of living so in that brutally
paradoxical way raised the possibility
that just at the point where there's
nothing left we will be able to
appreciate it what we had which is kind
of where we are today however having
said that I think the Chinese are
actually coming along more rapidly than
we in the West have when it comes to the
environment so that was also very
heartening to see but the main thing was
just the sort of shock of being in
certainly the most Republican place I've
ever been
it seemed like just
the pristine vision of what bush-cheney
ISM leads to logically which is a money
and business centric society in utter
environmental ruin with this basically
weak central government that nonetheless
is very good at paranoid security and
stirring up patriotism and nationalism
and the country basically consisting of
some unbelievably rich people and a
significant relatively well-off group
and then a large and is rated underclass
and the country basically being run by
this kind of corrupt cominging of local
politicians regional politicians and
business interests who've just figured
out how to divide up the spoils and
maintain social order and some of that
is very exciting I mean there is the
let's give Bush Cheney is omits do
pre-katrina there was a certain kind of
excitement one felt like wow these
people are evil and the world is
changing but man they're so far ahead of
what the Democrats can do in terms of
political organization political
sophistication and militant eyes on the
prize you get knocked down here you lose
a division doesn't matter just pick up
and keep going that excitement that one
felt sort of circa 2003 2004 when Grover
Norquist seemed like the most prescient
person in America and Tom DeLay seemed
unstoppable and Titan that excitement is
there tenfold in China it's like wow
they're just going for it
and it's you know everything is getting
stapled on behind on an as-needed basis
there is no there's no way this thing's
going to work and yet it's kind of
working still it's so there's the it's
it's I just found it really the my
primary emotion was
excitement there and of course a deep
under current of sadness is somebody who
cares about nature